[Musique]
et bien c'est demain le grand jour pour
l'astronaute david saint jacques qui va
décoller pour la station spatiale
internationale à bord de la fusée soyouz
avec l'astronaute américaine ann mclean
et la sono du russe oleg kononov co pour
en parler d'elle je reçois mon collègue
l'animateur de découverte charles
tisseyre bonjour charles
vous allez suivre en direct demain avec
mon collègue marc andré masson le
décollage david saint-jacques à des
collages qui soulève quand même
certaines inquiétudes avec ce qui s'est
passé au mois d'octobre où on se
souvient que le 11 octobre une fusée
soyouz n'a pas pu compléter son
ascension jusqu'à leur [ __ ] il ya eu une
défaillance mais ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que le système de
sécurité le système de sauvetage
d'urgence a fonctionné absolument
brillamment ce qui veut dire que les
instruments sont revenus sains et saufs
sur terre après avoir subi des
accélérations dollars 2,7 g ce qui a été
quand même important mais ils sont
entraînés pour ça et les astronautes
sont confiants les russes sont confiants
ils ont fait ils ont fait une enquête
rapide ils ont découvert la cause de ce
problème
c'était un capteur sur des propulseurs
d'appoint il ya une grappe de
propulseurs d'appoint autour de la fusée
principal qui doivent se détacher après
deux minutes et on a trois qui sont bien
détaché le quatrième c'est mal détacher
la perforé un réservoir de carburant et
la fusée a commencé à tanguer dans tous
les sens c'est comme ça que la cam s'il
a pu s'échapper
ils ont trouvé le problème sont
confiants d'avoir réparé donc c'est une
fusée qui est très sécuritaire qui a eu
plus de 60 lancement réussi il ya eu un
lancement d'un vaisseau cargo il ya
quelques semaines à peine
avec une réussite totale une fusée
identique dans tout le monde est
confiant
donc après c'est tout devrait bien se
passer davet saint-jacques le dit
lui-même sa confiance n'avait nullement
été ébranlé sa renforcer sa
concentration
vous allez suivre quoi plus exactement
pendant
on va suivre les d'abord ce qui se passe
sur le pas de tir juste avant le
lancement comme les astronautes se
prépare comme on prépare la capsule et
le vaisseau pour le décollage
ensuite on va suivre le décollage remain
qui est assez spectaculaire
quand on pense qu'on compass 2 0 km à
l'heure à 25000 km à l'heure en 9
minutes
c'est une accélération assez remarquable
il ya différentes phases dans
l'ascension et ce qui est remarquable
encore une fois dans le cadre du soyouz
ces cas toutes les phases de
l'association s'il se passe quelque
chose il ya moyen de ramener les
astronomes ça c'est assez formidable
donc on va suivre cette ascension la
morale est dit qu on va la décrire on va
surtout écouter ce qui se passe et on va
raconter ce qui ce qui se passe étape
par étape et tout ça ça va se dérouler
sous les yeux des enfants de la vie de
ces gens qui sont là sur place avec les
pauses d'avc gens que ça c'est
exceptionnel
ou est ce sont des modes ce sont des
moments stressants
ce sont des moments émotifs bien sûr
mais ils ont été bien préparée par david
et par toute l'équipe
ça fait partie de la vie de la famille
de l'astronaute et de l'astronomie mais
on peut se demander pourquoi ce que les
astronautes font ça mais ce parce que ce
sport pourquoi ce qu'un oiseau doit
voler on peut pas l'empêcher c'est dans
leur nature et la famille si je puis
dire et solidaire embarque dans ce
projet là la famille fait partie de
l'équipe de david saint-jacques donc ils
sont enthousiastes à l'idée de voir
partir mais bien sûr c'est pas comme
traverser la rue monte dans un soyouz
c'est quand même quelque chose de das et
en dehors de l'ordinaire il a des années
d'entraînement et sélectionnez
astronautes canadiens
il ya une dizaine d'années par m'aider
les décors étaient originaires de saint
lambert en boule diriger cette mission
là elle va durer six mois c'est la plus
longue pour un astronaute canadien non
parce que chris hadfield après la
mission de six mois aussi il était même
le commandant de la station spatiale
internationale
et c'est le but d'une longue mission
comme celle à vos postes cacher ses
défauts préparer les êtres humains pour
un long voyage vers la planète mars
parce que ça prend six mois se rendre à
la planète mars au fond tu fais un
voyage à la planète mars dans la station
spatiale orbitale pendant six mois et
alors on peut analyser des fonctions
corporelles pour voir comment des os
peuvent se dégrader dans la pesanteur
comment ton système cardiovasculaire
peut être influencée comment ton sens de
l'orientation dans l'espace peut être
affectée par la pesanteur la
microgravité
ici il ya un bar gauche droite et dans
l'espace quand arrive ou et le haut ou
le bas tu flottes dans le vaisseau
spatial et donc david saint-jacques va
travailler justement lors d'expériences
canadienne sur ces aspects là entre
autres de la mission recherche
scientifique et recherche médicale et on
va le voir dans les prochaines minutes
ce matin lors de sa dernière apparition
publique avant de partir demain matin il
va répondre à des questions des médias
il serait fort intéressant d'entendre ce
qu'il aura à dire c'est merci d'avoir
été là